In this video, we'll look at how the player can be linked to the new interactive elements in our level.
To start, we're going to take a look at another unique feature to Unreal, the Level Blueprint.
This is a great place for quickly prototyping interactions,
because in the same way that a regular Blueprint has an innate understanding of everything inside of it,
the Level Blueprint has an innate understanding of everything in that level,
which makes it very easy to create references and link different Actors and their components together.
Just be careful you don't rely on this too much,
as you have to duplicate everything from one Level Blueprint to the next.
So if you want to have code that's reusable, you're going to need to have that exist in standalone Actors.
To open the Level Blueprint, we can simply come up here to this Blueprint button,
which gives us a list of everything in the level, and we can see here, open Level Blueprint.
Right now, this is just blank.
We're going to delete both of these,
and we're going to start by once again adding a space bar.
We'll continue to use that for triggering our logic.
If we're wondering how can we now get a reference to our Dancer,
as well as the Stage or the Material Parameter Collection
that's controlling the color of our material for our columns,
we're going to be able to do that in a couple ways.
The first, we can make a variable here,
click on the dropdown, and we'll call this Color NPC.
We will change its type to Material.
You can see we get a long list of everything matching what we're typing in,
and this is the one we want.
Material Parameter Collection, hit Compile, and we can set its type to Session Color Change.
In order to get a version of our Dancer,
what we need to do is click on them in the level so they're selected,
come over here, and now we can right-click and create a reference to our Demo Dancer.
Instead of needing to do a whole searching for an actor of a specific class
and saving them in a variable,
we can just quickly get them right here in our Blueprint.
From this, we want to get our Skeletal Mesh component.
We don't need this, but we do need this.
We want to get the Animation Instance,
so the Animation Blueprint that is tied to our Skeletal Mesh in that scene.
We'll get an Instance, perfect.
And then from here, we want to be able to call that Dance Toggle event
on that Animation Blueprint.
What we can do is drag off, and we're going to use a Cast node.
This is something kind of unique to C++ and Blueprints.
Session Demo Dancer, there we are.
Casting is maybe a little bit confusing to get your head around at first,
but essentially what this allows us to do is ask if this object that we're inputting,
can we treat this object as this ABP Session Demo Dancer?
If they match, so if this object is this class or a child of it,
then we succeed, and we can execute our logic.
In this case, we can pull off, search for Session Dance Toggle.
There it is, and voila.
If the cast fails, so it is whatever we get through here,
it is not an ABP Session Demo Dancer.
Then this Cast Failed pin will execute,
and we can, for fun, just have a print string saying,
Not Demo Dancer.
We know something went wrong.
So we want to be able to, before we just pipe this in here,
we also want our space bar to simultaneously be able to change
our color of our material.
So if we want a single, we could, just once this finishes,
be able to drag off from here and start going into maybe another,
our logic that would control that.
But one thing we can do that's another handy node is a Sequence node.
This allows you to kind of structure your code a little bit more legibly
and have it going down versus scrolling off to the side in infinity,
and you can add more output pins depending on how many things you want in your sequence,
and then you can right-click to remove any that you don't need.
We'll come down to here.
We'll look for a flip-flop again,
and we want to get our reference to our stage pillar
or our color material parameter collection.
We're also going to need a variable for text.
So this is going to be our text.
This is when we see from here,
when we pull, I'm getting ahead of myself slightly,
but in order to set the value of that parameter, we have to have its name.
So if we do set scalar parameter value,
this is what we can use to change it from 0 to 1
and change the color of our material,
but we need to pipe in a name here.
So I guess we'll change this to parameter name.
Always helpful to know what everything is.
We can just send the type of name to grab this.
I kind of like sometimes to situate them up here if I have the room to do that.
You can have your own preferences to how you like to arrange your nodes.
We will set this to, what do we call it?
Color change A to B.
Copy that.
Plug that in here.
Fantastic.
And so the first time we're setting it as a default to 0,
the first time we want to switch it to 1.
We can duplicate this.
And then once again drag these down.
Set this to 0 the second time.
And now we should be good to go here.
I'm remembering though in our demo dance
that I believe we might have set up our base bar logic.
Where did we do that?
We didn't do that yet.
This had the space bar logic to spin.
That's right.
Okay.
So now we should be good to go here.
If we press play, press space.
Oh, consuming input.
So here's another nice trick to know.
One thing that's important to look out for.
Why didn't our demo dancer here change their dance?
Well, if we open up our spin cube here again
and look for our space bar,
we can see that consume input here is checked.
So this will mean that this instance of this node
on this specific blueprint will use our space bar input.
And nothing else in our project that uses this space bar input node
will be able to get that input.
So if we uncheck this, save,
and we come over here and make sure this is also unchecked.
Save these.
Now, if we play, we should see.
There we go.
Fantastic stuff.
Both the cube changes spinning direction,
and the dancer changes their dance.
However, we're seeing that we do not have
our super cool material on our boxes yet.
So in order to be able to see our new material
on the pillars around our stage,
we're going to need to be able to see two materials
on that FBX at the same time.
So in order to do that,
we're actually going to reimport this stage object here.
We're going to come up.
I have a version of it here that does not have
the parent selected when we were exporting the FBX out of Unity,
which I'll show, go back and show in a sec.
But we want to make sure we also have this checkbox enabled here,
keep section separate.
So I'll go ahead and import.
We'll say yes to these.
And now when we open it up,
we can see that we have a bunch of new material slots
for our individual pillars, which is what we want.
So let's copy this location here.
And actually, we can just copy the whole transform.
Then we can delete this,
bring in our stage here.
And it looks like we applied a rotation when we imported it.
So that looks like it is correct.
And that's looking good.
So now we have a bunch more materials here.
So what we can do is drag in our...
Where was our new material? There it is, stage pillar mat.
We'll drag that in here.
There we go.
Fun stuff.
I'll save.
Now when we press play, look at that.
Now for an activity,
let's take the logic that we've created in the level blueprint
and break that out into individual blueprints
for our dancer and our stage
so that we can reuse them in other levels.
In the next video,
we'll look at how we went through this on our end together.